There you go.
[Silence]
Awesome.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
foram.
foreign.
[Silence]
Alass,
here We have a narration in the vein
that we started yesterday in the vein of
the virtue of knowledge.
Well, in this narration, our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam he teaches us
that there are only two types of people
who are worthy
of our envy. And what's meant here by
envy is not the destructive
type of jealousy
that consumes a person.
Jealousy,
envy.
This is like
drinking poison
and hoping that the person you are
jealous of dies from it. That's what
jealousy and envy does to a person. It
blackens your heart.
And even the mushri
of ancient Greece and Rome and Persia
even they understood the dangers of
envy
where they
mention and they give examples of the
envious one is a person who eats
snakes who eats poisonous snakes in
their mythology and And that is because
of the destruction that envy and
jealousy reeks on the heart of the
person who is jealous or envious. What's
meant here in this context of jealousy
is that a person wishes for himself
something similar.
You see someone who has something,
someone that
you are jealous of in this context means
that you wish you had what that person
has. Not that you wish that person
didn't have it. Not that you wish you
had it so you could be better than
someone else. This is always
destructive.
Rather, what's intended here is that you
wish you had what this person had.
There's only two types of people worthy
of that from you.
Our prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
mentions two types of people.
Number one, a person who has knowledge.
A person who has knowledge of the Quran
and Sunnah and he teaches it and
implements it. That person is worthy of
your envy in this way.
And the second type is a person whom
Allah has given wealth to
spend that wealth for the sake of Allah.
A person who has wealth
and then spends that wealth
to access avenues of Allah's pleasure.
Those are avenues that are not open to
someone who doesn't have that wealth.
You physically cannot do it. You may
have the intention of doing it. You may
have the wish of doing it, but if you
don't have that wealth, you're unable to
do it.
And so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that there are two
things
that
two instances where another person is
worthy of your envy in this way. He says
the first is a man whom Allah has given
wealth to and he concentrates spending
this wealth on the truth meaning on
the things that please Allah. He uses
this wealth to garner pleasure from
Allah. The second is a person whom Allah
has given knowledge to. In this
narration, in this particular wording,
he says hikma and hikma literally
translates to wisdom. But in the diction
of the Quran, al hiknah
is knowledge of the Quran and sunnah
in its implementation
and its nuances.
This is what wisdom is.
And so here is not just knowledge of the
Quran and Sunnah but knowledge of the
intricacies of the Quran and Sunnah. The
secrets, the nuances,
the subtleties, the details of the book
of Allah and the Sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to the point where
it becomes wisdom. This person now
sees with the wisdom of the Quran. He
hears with the wisdom of the Quran. He
analyzes with the wisdom of the Quran.
He speaks with the wisdom of the Quran.
Because the Quran flows through his
veins
along with his blood.
He breathes the Quran. He speaks. He
implements. He embodies the Quran and
Sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. And what is the sunnah
but the understanding of the Quran?
That's what the sunnah is, right? It's
the prophet's understanding of the
Quran. Correct? And that's why Allah
refers to the sunnah as hikma al hikmma
in the Quran. He says to the wives of
the prophet Sam,
[Silence]
Al Quran.
And so why does Allah refer to the
Sunnah as hikma?
Because it is the understanding, the
prophetic understanding of the Quran.
And most of the Sunnah or a lot of it at
least is derivative of the Quran.
And this is why Allah sent a messenger.
So that Allah says to the prophet, we
have sent the Quran down to you so that
you will teach people and show them the
understanding, the implementation of the
Quran. That's the whole point of the
Sunnah.
And so in short,
any other person
outside of these two types of people,
they're not worthy of your your envy.
They're not worthy of your aspirations.
They're not worthy of you to aspire to
be this person. And this is not an
easy feat. If this were easy, if it were
easy to spend your money for the sake of
Allah, he didn't just say spend it for
the sake of Allah. He said
is to spend it as if you are trying to
get rid of it for the sake of Allah.
That's a very different breed of person.
That's a very different person. Right?
[Silence]
and so the point here is that these are
not easy feats. In order for a person to
be given wealth, to acquire wealth,
that's okay one part of it. But to spend
it for the sake of Allah in this way,
this is very difficult. You have to go
through a serious
a serious metamorphosis in your heart
of hearts to be able to trust Allah
enough to spend your wealth for the sake
of Allah you're trying to get rid
of it. you are trying to get rid of
it. person is thinking now Yesh
this is dangerous people now are going
to start spending their wealth because
you no we don't have a problem with this
who do you know has a problem with
spending too much for the sake of Allah
you've never met this person we don't
have an issue with this we have an issue
with h spending begrudgingly for the
sake of Allah or if we do something out
of the ordinary we really really, you
know, look at that and we try to ride
that wave for a long time. Who of us has
ever given half of everything he
possesses in one go for the sake of
Allah?
This was a common occurrence in the time
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
when they were preparing for one battle.
He came and he brought half of all of
his wealth. Half of it
gave it all for this preparation of this
battle. Sure that this time he had beat
Abu Bakr and Abu Bakr Sud came with all
of his wealth. What does that mean all
of his wealth? His wealth is
regenerating, right? He has income
coming in. But he took everything he had
at the moment to zero
and gave it all in one go.
Allah sends down the verse.
Abu Tala
hears this verse comes to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and says
here is beh
par parcel of land that is rich very
rich soil
palm trees it was so enjoyable it had
its own water source it had a well in it
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to go there to rest and
to reprieve find reprieve there
as soon As he heard this verse, he came
and said, "This is the best that I own.
Here it is for the sake of Allah." All
of it.
Another story.
We have
stories of companions
who
give away everything that they have
and then they come home and tell their
wife, "Come on, bring all the stuff out
of the house. I gave this away for the
sake of Allah. I dare you to do that.
Huh?
And someone would say, "Well, this is
special. They're special. How are they
special? Are these things we're not
supposed to do?
Who Who's going to do this? Or is this a
lost part of our religion?
It's gone. Nobody does that stuff
anymore. Come on. That that was a good
that was a generation that are beyond
us. But that stuff that's not for us,
you know. I'm just a regular guy. I just
give my little $5 on J right as I'm
leaving and and and that's where I go
impulsively spending your money for the
sake of Allah. you're trying to get
rid of it. Why? Because you are certain
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's promise.
No charity given has ever has ever
depleted a person's wealth. Not ended
it, depleted it. It's never depleted it.
Now there are verses in the Quran such
as the statement of Allah
to be moderate in your spending even
for the sake of Allah. This is in the
majority of your dealings.
But there are instances where you give
extreme amounts. Let me ask you a
question.
These things that I just mentioned,
these stories, I don't think a single
one of us has never heard them. We've
all heard these stories, right? Okay.
Here's a question that I have. If
somebody were to do this today,
we would consider this in our culture
today to be what? What's the word we
would give something this?
Extreme. Yeah, we'd call it extreme,
right? to give everything that you
have right now. give it all
for the sake of Allah at this moment. We
would say that's extreme, right? What
about if your son got sick?
Would you give it all
and spend it all on medical bills?
Would you? If your son got sick, if your
daughter got sick, would you spend it
all? Would you think twice? You would
think that's very heroic. Correct. So,
it's not extreme then. It is not extreme
because there are instances where we
would say that's correct. What we are
really saying when we say that's extreme
is to do it for that reason is extreme.
This is the difference between us and
the companions.
They
save those extremes for the sake of
Allah.
We will often see these extremes being
practiced but for something of the
dunya. Your son, my son, your daughter,
my daughter. I have three children.
They're going to die eventually. No
matter what you do, they're going to be
dust.
The best thing you can do for them is
teach them these kinds of extremes.
Subhanahu wa'tala.